[Music]
hello Wolfgang I've been getting some
specific requests to talk about whether
or not Quicksilver will be in Avengers
infinity war no not that one that one
Marvel released a TV spot trailer and
what some fans think that they saw
Quicksilver running around and will
Khanda in the background and this video
will be dissecting the footage in which
everyone thinks they saw Quicksilver
running around in the background and how
it could possibly link to the comics
before we dive into it be a friend and
subscribe to my channel also quick
spoiler alert not sure if any of this
could be true if he could be in the
movie but you've been warned
okay so here's the clip of where
everyone thinks they see Quicksilver
running around in the background did you
catch it
most likely not so we'll slow it down
for you and be sure to look for that
blue line in the background what about
now did you see it before we decide if
this is actually Quicksilver or not
let's take a step back and talk about
whether it's even possible for him to
return the short answer is yes of course
you can return the directors can do
anything they want we already saw them
bring Agent Coulson back and agents of
shield and that was in a really weird
way go ahead and look up project Tahiti
there are more logical ways that he
could be revived such as in the comics
he's revived by gues ooh that's right
his sister you didn't see that's coming
in the House of M comic storyline
magneto actually kills Quicksilver in
which the Scarlet Witch revives him
granted this happens a few minutes after
Quicksilver dies and infinity war will
take place many years after sokovia but
it could happen so yes he could be
brought back to life in several
different ways some we probably wouldn't
even a dream to think of so let's take a
look at this blue line in the background
of Wakanda it starts to left and goes
all the way to the right this does sort
of resemble quicksilver's beam that
we've seen in Avengers age of Ultron
with the exception of this beam being a
little bit more blue than age of Ultron
so I can definitely see how some fans
would think that this is in fact
Quicksilver we actually went sifting
through some of the other trailers that
have been released to see if there is
any more seen such like this and we
found one more it's also really hard to
see it in this scene - so we'll slow it
down for you it's really hard to tell
but this almost looks like it could be
Quicksilver running but if you want my
personal opinion no I do not think this
is Quicksilver sorry to say it because I
do wish that they would bring
Quicksilver back into the movie and who
knows they may do it this just may not
be him and I think we'd all like to see
a reunion between the Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver but to me this just doesn't
look like Quicksilver and if you look
closely there doesn't seem to be any
sort of human shape to this line it just
looks like a ball to me this looks like
a shot coming out of one of sharees
blasters so this could simply just be an
attack coming from shariah against
somebody who's really far away or it
could be from a wakandan soldier it
would make sense that they all have the
technology and the weapons available
they may even have some sort of huge
tank that sends a giant blast from
really far distances so my opinion is
that this is not Quicksilver sadly and
that this is some sort of a Condon
attack that does not mean that
Quicksilver won't be in the movie I just
don't think that this is him in this
scene but hey I could definitely be
wrong what do you guys think did you
take a close look did you see something
that I could have maybe missed let me
know let's talk about it in the comments
if you liked this video please be sure
to hit that little thumbs up button and
if you're a fan of the Avengers Marvel
movies and Marvel Comics and all things
superhero subscribe to my channel for
more videos thank you so much for
watching stay golden Wolfgang
if I could save time in a bottle the
first thing that I'd like to do is to
save every day till eternity